you
you are a fine fish i
only need three more years for i can
think like a fish i'm already thinking
like a dead stone fight
pictures mother's pictures
a river runs through it was an excellent
movie based on an even better book
a story of love and loss family and
fishing
the author was norman mclean who didn't
publish his magnum opus until he was 74
years old
it catapulted him into the pantheon of
great american writers
and set the standard for generations of
what a great novella
could be it also introduced millions of
americans to the beauty
of fly fishing norman passed away in
1990 but his influence lives on
his son long time journalist john mclean
is out with a chronicle looking back on
that story
his family and the impact of his
father's legacy
it's called home waters
[Music]
this could be the one i fished the
blackfoot river in northwestern montana
from the time i was big enough to tag
along with my father
and the other men of my family yearning
for the day when i
like them would catch an enormous
rainbow trout
the river's signature fish john mcclane
has been wrestling with a river
for the better part of his life as he
writes in his new book
home waters many go through life without
glimpsing heaven and hell
but fishing with my father gave me an
early appreciation of both
the book is a tribute to the place and
people who defined him
i describe the book as sort of a river
it meanders it picks up steam and parts
and then
slows down you go all over the place i
do
but it's the same river
that river is the big blackfoot in
western montana
the setting for an all-time great
american adventure
in our family there was no clear line
between religion and fly fishing
a novella about an uncompromising
reverend and his wife and two sons
a river runs through it contains some of
the greatest opening and ending lines in
literary history
the river was cut by the world's great
flood and runs over rocks
from the basement of time not
surprisingly
it captured the attention of hollywood i
am haunted by waters
norman mclean based the characters on
his own family drawing from his
experiences growing up in montana in the
early 1900s
including the tragic killing of his
brother john mclean's uncle paul
a journalist who lived a wild and short
life of hard drinking
gambling and bar room brawls how much of
a river runs through it
is truth versus fiction it is
a vision it is not a factual
non-fiction narrative and
you just have to accept that i think
what is true about it
is the way my father felt about it and
the way it
acted on him and shaped his life and now
shapes the lives of others and that is a
different kind of truth what do you say
big blackfoot in the movie john's
famously mysterious uncle was portrayed
by brad pitt if not for paul that
novella never happens
if paul had not been murdered there
would have been no river runs through it
none of my six books uh things would
have been very very different
have you tried to wrap your head around
that ever i have
yes and i tried to wrap my head around
that when i was riding home waters
which is what is this guy's legacy by
describing his relationship with his
brother
and how he tried to reach out to him and
failed and
gave him a part of himself that was
basically refused
and taking that to an eloquent level
he brought comfort and consolation to a
whole group of people
who have siblings that they have tried
to reach
that they have tried to help and that
they have failed to touch
because you have to come to terms with
the fact that some people you just can't
reach
well that you still make the outreach
john like his uncle became a journalist
working for the chicago tribune covering
politics in dc for decades
before he turned to books in the late
90s he has since written five
non-fiction books about devastating
western fires
his latest turn to his family's legacy
may be more relevant than ever
we're coming out of a pandemic one thing
people discovered is that the outer
world which we're in right now makes a
big difference
you can come out here it's more or less
free
it takes a bit of work to get here and
it gives back
a sense of belonging a sense of being
somebody
that's connected to things that can
sustain you and connect you to your own
family
the montana john's father wrote about
looks a lot different today
on seeley lake where we met motorboats
have mostly replaced the canoes
john still prefers development and
dollars have moved in
everywhere not all of it bad wetlands
have been restored
and fish populations on the blackfoot
rebounded dramatically
the movie changed everything it changed
montana
uh the book of the movie now defined
what montana is and it
is getting overrun in some very good
ways
in some very good ways i mean what
happened with the restoration the
restoration
story uh is a story of a lot of money
pouring in and local people using it
very well
and it has become a model for how to
restore other waters
at age 78 john mcclane still works
out of the modest cabin his dad revered
he's hoping the next generation will
keep it going
even if his father never professed much
interest in leaving a trace
when was this put in oh gosh i was
trying to remember
uh very early 90s right after my dad was
gone
do people come to see this uh this has
become a big deal
and while you could do without the
traffic sometimes you like that people
want to pay tribute uh you've got it
exactly right
it's always fascinated me that there's
no pictures
of your dad available actually fishing
why is that uh well we didn't do a lot
of that i mean you take
snapshots after you were done people
didn't carry cameras while they were
fishing
and also he was a little shy about that
kind of thing
it only adds to the mystery well you
know again it's
the unseen that makes the whole thing
work what makes fishing work it's what
makes
paul work it's what makes a lot of good
writing work it isn't what you put into
it it's what you leave out
yes yes indeed
and it's what makes this book work uh
there's never a time when i pick up
river when i don't
want to just keep reading it there's
never a time when i visit this part of
montana
when i want to go home it's just
gorgeous it is
i just think about the tragedy in the
life
being sort of an open to so much
good that came out of these two lives
complications good good and bad but yes
how that one murder affected
so many lies and the question that you
asked if you tried to wrap your head
around
how things would have changed if it was
different fascinating has been forever
yeah